hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch an
honest trailer we haven't watched one of
these in a while well I kind of watch
them weekly we haven't done a reaction
to one in a while
this one just sounded way too damaged
reading it's called MC you how the hell
are they gonna do an honest trailer for
all those films just one video I don't
know before we get into that I wanted to
mention that I am going to be back on
movie fights next week I was on movie
fights not long ago actually the live
stream sort of cut out so they had to
reload it at like midnight affected some
of the view count but that is actually
one of my personal favorite movie fights
I was there with Trisha Hershberger
Mikey McCarthy you know how rudnick
hosting it was a great episode really
loved it I hope that you guys to go
check it out there's a link in the
description box and pin comment and keep
a lookout when I'm on there next week I
think supposed to go on screen junkies
news as well just the screen junkies day
with all the junkies at the screen junk
that's what's presented by the boys
taking the fight to superheroes on
Amazon Prime video on July 26 that's
superhero show Urban
do them all 300 ah special episode I
love you 300 in a World Bank comic book
company he sold the film rights to its
best characters for peanuts because they
thought movies would be a good way to
sell more comics a young executive with
the rejects that no one wanted freedom
do so well they get caught out by Disney
before it was cool cinematic universe
except for a game well hack Thomson a TV
series made of movies about comic books
where magic is actually science your
answer physical data magic and you call
it science but not by magic by
technology magic science and meet your
typical MCU protagonist a loner with no
pets no biological siblings and whose
only friends are their co-workers Oh
whose personality can range from my
heartache whipster is closed today to
stir duty-bound military-type get hurt
quarterback get killed walk it off and
in a long enough timeline everyone
becomes equipped to follow along on
their hero's journey as far by
motivating Uncle Ben's situation they'll
get a transformational hairstyle
cut some cards and find the strength to
boat they say their superhero name out
loud so so who I'm an I'm Peter with me
not just rich um I'm spider-man then
starring mm-hmm a hero is only as good
as their villain and thank god that's
not true or the MCU would be hard to
have surreal as they spare 10 minutes to
establish a bad guy who's just like the
hero but II
or a faceless horde can't feel bad if it
doesn't have a face or actually a pretty
awesome character and there but everyone
knows the real villain of the MCU his
dad he was cold he was calculating he
never told me before the girth of a
meticulously planned story told across
23 separate movies all about Thanos
killing half the universe well first he
has to get an Infinity Gauntlet no yeah
and gathered the Infinity stones well
send proxies to get them and he gives
one away but eventually he'll get the
stones some are stones one of the other
etics often appear as stones the ether
is fluid but then he'll kill half the
universe which also visiting much says
Oh also the timeline doesn't work out
freaking so many mazes wasn't so play
that after all but the film's do so
nicely into three distinct phases the
conventional pop songs phase half of
boundary-pushing experimental phase and
if rock duck Satomi anyone face for
while I begin to see you puking in the
gutter wondering where it all went wrong
let's hope not are this regions of
liking space to others dimensions to the
wonders of Earth oops that one Zootopia
and Wow and how everything still kind of
looks and feels the same as visionary
indie filmmakers are funneled into the
Marvel style of over live digital video
where everything is CGI please don't be
is full of sexless romance that never
takes off yes
bloodless violence
then there were leaves more than a
couple of foreheads grapes little bad
for drunken blood lifeless soundtracks
with more dad rock then you can shake a
pair of middle-aged screenwriters add
feel so good Chuck Mangione in 1977
Marvin Gaye 1972 Trouble Man soundtrack
toothless comedy that's just saying pop
culture things so this has loved you in
A Christmas Story shooting writer or
touring with his band in Germany no hard
feelings right you got a mean swing I
knew they'd go dead still what try me
Beyonce
Batman is playing you Steve is really
old movie aliens we're getting no help
from Flash Gordon exactly is a personal
fight that's big Souls ah so sibling
interconnected movie burst it had a 1 in
14 million 605 shot of working but those
odds didn't stop every other studio for
properly matching their IDs together
like a junior high dance floor leaving
marble as the only one standing in a
dying industry to do this other but
watch man a whole new industry of Marvel
movie news theory and analysis channels
that just complain about Marvel movies
and even comedy web series that would
have died a long time ago if Marvel
movies weren't so popular they didn't so
one way or another in the end
everyone's getting paid by Disney you
shills good science geniuses quantum
phasing an object moves through
different states of matter and I start
roasting great she's a theoretical
connection between two different points
of space via quantum system would revert
back to separate states of matter
I didn't you just reprogram the synapses
to what connected you when did you
become an expert in thermonuclear
astrophysics
lastly jumping out of here yeah
[Music]
and face yep like scissors that's all
black widows yeah oh oh nevermind one
wasn't black Twitter no oh wait a minute
for I mean majority
[Music]
Odie's yeah then you get a Hyundai and
you like it dual wheel being
[Music]
Wow there are so many tropes I just
never know smooth my record 21 bad you
65 huge 65 you get an answer and you get
Iron Man Iron Man suit
weird non Stanley cameos ya must
[Music]
oh dear combos
[Music]
yeah are you sure you know how to fly
this thing see one they're sitting in
star-lords jizz on a blacklight they
look like a Jackson Pollock painting
gross dude the neverending story it's
good we forgot to say anything about the
ABC shows Netflix series one Johnson
spin-offs
all about Twilight fans yes yes you get
it right real fan would know that you
know what they didn't point out how they
paid tribute to the Star Wars with the
arm getting cut off
yes brother point it out a lot of even
have his arms in hand that even happens
at any game there's usually someone who
gets that hand cut off in one of the MCU
movies and I guess I don't need to point
out the sky beams when I was trailer for
sky beam into its yeah I first noticed
it from when they pointed it out in some
honest trailer figures like ninja
turtles or something culminating in the
same blue beam sky home finale as every
other movie this decade uh what is up
with the 2010s and sky holes then I
started knows oh yeah that is a common
trope guy beams now I will really did
accentuate that but this is great there
were so many Trump's I've just never
picked up on this was a lot like the Wes
Anderson one to me picking out all these
different elements that I looked past
and yeah just wouldn't have thought of
since the movies are so spaced out over
time it's probably for the best that
Kevin Feige never really acknowledged
those television shows especially with
what they have going on now with a
Disney streaming service where they're
gonna go a lot more connective with the
actual films whereas you probably run
yourself into a weird corner if you
really did go out of your way to connect
especially those
Netflix shows because those all just got
the boot out of nowhere and I'm sure
they saw it coming in some fashion I've
never seen ages a shield or any of those
shows but for the Netflix ones I'm like
well it's probably best you didn't go
out of your way to connect those now it
was always a bummer they didn't get
acknowledged specifically the Netflix
ones because those were the ones I
watched and I want to be acknowledged
yeah I mean there are people who watch
those ABC ones who didn't watch the
Netflix ones but they don't matter what
matters is they should have gotten the
Netflix ones in there I mean I watched a
lot of The Runaways but it's cool watch
The Runaways to watch the full first
season is that canceled I don't know I
haven't heard anything about the season
three has anybody knows anyone watch
these into can you comment and tell us
what was any good by watching cloak and
dagger but the countless times low-keyed
I'd be considered a a trope I feel like
that's a maybe a second-tier Marvel
trope for sure Loki's never reliably
dies well yeah he's died or been locked
up and he think he's gone and now he's
getting his own show so he's always
coming back no one's ever really dead in
the MCU yeah I love the thing that they
said about the dads I don't know how I
ever missed that as someone like me who
goes to therapy I feel like I would
notice that you know all the daddy
issues that come into play but man that
is so prevalent in the MCU some of these
are like nitpick trope whereas this dad
thing seems to go over a hall of like
the main the main MCU films from Iron
Man to Loki is a relationship that the
whole concept of Thanos put Gamora a
nebula I never put that together and oh
he's so damn every frickin star-lord
with ego I'm actually like blown away by
how I totally missed that when it goes
to show to why all of a lot of the
heroes anyway are so competitive with
each other and have a certain element of
you know compensation Ulm achieves moe
yeah cuz they've all got troubles with
their dad they're all just trying to
live up to him and and yeah prove
they're good enough I'm half asian now
that they're gonna be doing a Asian led
MCU foam with shang-chi now you can
finally get the trope of neglectful
disciplinary mom for shang-chi have that
be a driving force to university man
I think if Kevin Feige white genius
producer wants to capitalize on Asian
culture you got to have the neglectful
emotionally abusive Asian stereotype mom
in there oh definitely and let that be
the driving force we haven't gotten that
yet we've got all these terrible dads
but what about the awful moms what about
a bad mom I mean the most we've got is
Aunt May right now and she's killing the
game she's gonna rain she's super cool
and relatable I want to clarify I love
my mom I just don't want to get hit with
a sandal later so that's why yeah oh
yeah clarifying I do though yeah well
that turns you wants that's a different
thing white people trying to just take
advantage of Asian culture you're sick
provocative ways I'm talking to you Joe
started no they did bring up a good
point though what is Marvel phase 4
gonna be like that I like the
correlation they made between how like
bands tend to go oh yeah that's a great
analogy so now we're hearing that
analogy here we go oh [ __ ]
does that mean phase 4 is gonna suck or
is phase 4 at least going to be strange
and bumpy while they figure out that
what the new yeah cuz they have trailed
late like they I thought that was
interesting they pointed out that like
so many franchises and and it's not a
new fact but to see them all kind of
together you're like it Marvel is the
one massive cinematic universe that is
truly and honestly working boundlessly
at the moment and no one else is doing
that really I wonder and I hope they
take advantage of the fact they're in a
position to try some new stuff out you
know we'll see we'll see
bottom line they made a great point we
are all Disney chills at the end of the
day are we are all owned by Disney in
some capacity and I'm ok with it yeah
sure why not
helps keep every YouTube channel in the
movie business alive I love how they
said they wouldn't cover any event game
but they [ __ ] please you've been to
space through a clip from spider-man far
from home area
you know we'll skip that but we'll use a
trailer moment from farver milk oh yeah
cuz Sony doesn't care as much as Marvel
does yeah yeah what did you think of
this honest trailer are there any tropes
that they did not point out you can
subscribe to the reject nation subscribe
to screen junkies keep a look out for
that movie fights episode click that
notification bell you know all that crap
youtubers say like buttons exist and
last but not least I would like to give
a page from the day shout out to a
lovely lady named Rosa Parra known as
the Lady Stark of our channel and
fortunately because lady Stark wasn't in
season 8 it's still a very positive
thing to say okay I wanted to say I love
you guys she gives great reviews she has
her own Instagram and Twitter page or on
site Rosa reviews I follow her on
Instagram and Twitter and every time she
posts on Instagram I always read her
little blog post reviews it's always
great getting her opinions she's
constantly doing giveaways five years in
we've never done a giveaway were greedy
but she does plenty of save aways it
sounds hard and time-consuming why would
I do that for the people who love us
know the Rosa you're something special
oh yeah much love to you and a happy
belated Mother's Day shouts out to
Cassandra and the rest of your children
yeah we own another name we don't know
the rest of their names